let's bring in Peter King NBC sports.com
football morning in America must read
every Monday morning his column anger
apologies in videos gone viral inside
the three days that sparked majors shift
in the NFL Peter how are we and I'm
doing well how about yourself well I'm
trying to sort this out with what has
transpired here over the last four or
five days with the NFL starting I guess
with Drew Brees apology
subsequent apology and then another
apology the Commissioner then putting
out the video and then the president
tweeting last night so where do you
think the dust is settled so far here on
Monday morning before 10:00 a.m. you
know we'll see you know right now
basically I think the biggest thing
about what happened in the last few days
is that Roger Goodell who despite what
people think does listen to people
doesn't always act on what people close
to him say but Roger Goodell listened he
listened to the voices of 20 players led
by Michael Thomas he listened to some
rogue employees and it wasn't just
Brendan mentor the 27 year old social
media video producer sitting in his
apartment in LA and working at his
kitchen table and putting together one
of the most impactful player videos
we've ever seen that already in four
days got 21 million views across you
know all kinds of platforms it isn't
just that it's also the fact that Dan
when Roger Goodell had a Town Hall last
Friday an employee who's been with the
NFL for four months a guy named Eric
Walker former walk-on football player at
BC basically appealed to the
Commissioner to let's be the sport we
were on 9/11 when we helped America come
out of it let's be the sport we were in
Katrina when we helped America get well
we're not that sport right now and I
think that really hit rod
goodell the 31 year old black employee
along with many other black employees on
zoom video conferences a lot like the
one we're having right now basically
said we are not being heard and you were
not listening to your players in michael
thomas Tyrann Mathieu and the others a
Jarvis Landry Odell Beckham jr. looked
right at Roger Goodell and said you have
to listen to us and he did the
Commissioner puts out a statement and I
think you were reporting that the owners
didn't know that he was putting out this
statement we haven't heard from the
owners yet is that correct Pete no I
have not read anything I did not report
that Dan I think someone else did I
don't know who it was but but honestly
you know at this point
it isn't that that doesn't matter but
Roger Goodell was not going to get on
the phone with 32 owners and say hey
what do you think I'm thinking of doing
this he had to do this there's no
question about it the big question now
was I posed in my column is really
what's next what are the owners going to
do what's Jerry Jones going to do you
know what happened the last time when
there was a threat for people kneeling
there was an implicit you know
unemployed
you know statement from Jones any
implied he never said this directly but
don't you dare kneel on the sidelines of
my stadium so now we're gonna have to
see and look I think there's no question
that players are going to kneel perhaps
and mass uh you know this this fall at
games I mean there's there's three
months between now and opening day so
we'll see what happens a lot could
happen but I think what has happened in
the last few days is that the players
have flex their muscles in the NFL
listen well we got six weeks to training
camp whatever training camps gonna look
like and I was reading mark masky in the
Washington Post saying that there may be
there's a little bit more of a sentiment
or feel I don't I'm paraphrasing here of
maybe Colin Kaepernick
gets a true chance now have you heard
anything about anybody maybe opening
their eyes their doors to Colin
Kapernick here no it wouldn't shock me
but I don't expect it to happen and I
don't know I all I can do is have a gut
feeling on this dan if you were Colin
Kaepernick and got the opportunity to be
Jameis Winston or to be Andy Dalton and
it goes somewhere and be a backup no one
right now is he gonna hand Colin
Kaepernick a starting job yeah if you
had a chance to go somewhere and be a
backup and probably sit around for the
majority of the year do you want to do
that and maybe he will want to do that
and maybe he'll do it to make a point
but I would I doubt it what happened but
I have no information either way on I
said the same thing about 15 minutes ago
I just can't imagine that sort of all
this cloud he's built up as a voice or
his actions and then you go in and
you're a backup quarterback you know it
feels like he's more powerful in what he
wants by not being a backup quarterback
in the NFL Dan the CEO of Twitter just
handed him a check for three million
dollars to continue his work to educate
young people in his know your rights
camps and you know in somebody else I
forget who gave him a million dollars to
do that so you know he's he's and again
I have not talked to Colin Kaepernick in
four years so how would I know but I
think it's unlikely that he would take a
backup quarterback job in the NFL but
we'll see talking to Peter King the
column is football morning in America
Dru breezes apology would you make of
that
totally not surprising he's a team guy
we'll find out how serious he is and
whether indeed he's gonna stand with his
teammates he says he will and
dan as I wrote my column today there is
no one in the 36 years that I've covered
the NFL who has done more for his
adopted community that Drew Brees is
done for New Orleans nobody it's not
even close so I think everybody's a
little bit too quick to throw Drew Brees
off the cliff I think you have to give
him a chance
and whatever players think they're gonna
think okay but I think you got to give
him a chance to make this right
let me talk some football here as of now
the structure of you know offseason
workouts I mean is everything on
schedule from what you've learned of
this you know training camp and the
season starting on time yeah I mean I
talked to Alan sills the NFL's medical
director the other day and he said
everything right now as of right now is
on course to happen the way it normally
would now 11 teams won't be going away
to training camp all training camps will
be held at the home facilities we'll see
what kind of bubble can be built will
media be able to cover training camps
will they be the normal kind of training
camps they always have been
will there be preseason games you know
and those are the things we just don't
know right now the one thing I thought
sells so said this on Adam Schefter
podcast last week I thought it was a
great point he goes three months ago
I mean think of us three months ago
three months ago you and I were still
going out to dinner as normal and the
the first game of the regular season is
three months from this Wednesday so a
lot has happened in three months and a
lot can happen in the next three months
but all you can do is go by what you
think right now and the NFL I think in
adopting these positions these new jobs
like infection control officers in each
organization every facility is gonna be
spic-and-span the bubbles will be built
and we'll just see how it goes what's
your biggest question going into this
season football wise will the
the disease come back you know will the
second wave of the disease
ramrod itself into the United States on
December 10th and force the NFL to not
play football that's my biggest question
I think they're probably gonna start the
season and I think at one point or
another a big big star is gonna be held
out of a game because he tests positive
maybe there will be five of those on one
team and that team can't play this week
but I think the the overriding
overarching question is will the second
wave of the disease detour the NFL
season in week 12 14 16 what do you
think the NFL thinks about the month of
February of maybe extending the playoffs
or the week before the Super Bowl to get
that Super Bowl towards the end of
February basically let's own another
month is that part of that I mean it's
logical it's certainly you know they can
play the Super Bowl any one of those
Sundays in February in Tampa I'm sure
they could probably play it in March too
but you know again those are the kind of
things Dan that I just think nobody can
know right now because you know as
Anthony foutch he told me a month ago
the deceit the disease is gonna make
these decisions Peter thanks for joining
us appreciate all the words in your
column we appreciate your time as well
thank you Dan that's Peter King NBC
sports.com NFL columnist football
morning in America